Guten Morgen Linus.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik, Folge zweihundertsiebenundzwanzig aufgezeichnet am Dienstag, den achten August mit Thomas Loninger, Stadt Tim Prittlav.
Thomas, du äh bist dankenswerterweise eingesprungen, denn äh Tim macht eine Sprechpause, das hat der,
Vor einer Woche bekannt gegeben, bis dahin war's noch geheim, weil sowas sicher auch auf die Aktienkurse im Podcastgewerbe äh auswirkt, gab's da natürlich äh höchste Geheimhaltung, ne in Wirklichkeit konnte man das gar nicht geheim halten. Es ist schon vielen Hörern und Hörerinnen aufgefallen, dass der Tim deutlich heiser war.
Und da es hat dazu geführt, dass er vor einigen Tagen dann
operiert wurde, weil er einen kleinen Knoten an seinen Stimmbändern hatte, der einerseits durch Medikamente erfolgreich bekämpft werden konnte, aber leider nicht komplett verheilen wollte, sodass er dann doch noch einmal
zu einer kleinen Operation in die Klinik äh musste einmal Vollnarkose und zurück.
Und das ist alles ganz gut verlaufen. Äh ich glaube, was wenn Sachen rausgeschnitten werden, werden die auch nochmal irgendwie eingeschickt und untersucht, der ist auch irgendwie alles gut gelaufen, aber er hat,
eine Sprechpause verordnet bekommen, ich glaube zwar nicht, dass der Tim jetzt unbedingt weniger redet, wenn er nicht Podcast, aber ähm.
Er wird äh so den August nicht zur Verfügung stehen und zwar auf allen Kanälen. Das heißt auch so die anderen bekannten Formate der Metaebene fallen aus diesem Grund,
erstmal aus und er ist aber zuversichtlich spätestens im September wieder.
Voll einzusteigen, dankt allen Unterstützern und Spendern der Meterebene und äh hoffe, dass ihr ihm diese.
Diese Pause verzeihen werdet und äh ich hoffe,
ich es trotzdem schaffe ähm trotz Sommerloch und trotz äh fehlendem Tim hier wenigstens die ein oder andere Sendung äh in der Zeit aufzunehmen und ich hoffe, dass ihr eventuelle Widrigkeiten.
Wie vielleicht mal fehlende Kapitelmarken oder Sonstiges dann wiederum mir verzeihen werdet, weil ich ja eigentlich.
Äh normalerweise im Logbuch äh mich um die Technik nicht kümmere und ich hoffe äh dass ich das trotz allgemeiner Lernfaulheit in diesem Bereich äh trotzdem hier geklärt kriege. Und auch Thomas und ich wünschen natürlich dem Tim.
Äh eine gute Besserung und eine erholsame Sprechpause.
Ja, wenn's mal so still in der Meterebene ist, dann merkt man erst, was man eigentlich die ganze Zeit ähm gehabt hat, also auf jeden Fall gute Besserung für Tim. Ähm der darf uns nicht abhanden kommen.
Ja, nee, das also ich hoffe so.
So schlimm wird's auch nicht. Es ist um jemanden wie Tim äh dauerhafte det Sprechen äh zu nehmen äh müssen die schon mehr auffahren als irgendwie so eine halbe Stunde Vollnarkose.
Thomas, wenn wir dich in der Leitung haben, dann äh sprechen wir natürlich auch über die Proseedings in Österreich. Zuletzt haben wir mit dir gesprochen, den LMP zweihundertvierzehn. Die Sendung mit dem schönen Titel abstrakte Gefährder.
Und äh da hast du längere Zeit äh über das große Überwachungspaket,
gesprochen, was euch in Österreich nun beschäftigt. Insofern für alle äh wir werden, glaube ich, das Wichtigste nochmal zusammenfassen, aber wer da das große Bild noch einmal haben möchte, dem sei die LMP zweihundertvierzehn ans Herz gelegt, dir jetzt doch schon auch wieder.
Dreizehn Folgen her ist. Ähm, insofern.
Tragen wir dem natürlich Rechnung, dass das euch liebe Zuhörende ähm wahrscheinlich äh bei den ein oder anderen Stellen bisschen äh auf die Sprünge geholfen werden muss.
Und äh Thomas, lass uns doch mal hören, worum geht's im Überwachungspaket? Das klingt schon wieder nach so einer Sache. Da heißt, das heißt, da geht's gar nicht nur um eine Überwachungsmaßnahme, sondern um mehrere Welche denn.
Ja ganz viele, also die Geschichte beginnt irgendwie Ende Jenner, als die Regierung neues Arbeitsprogramm, neuen Koalitionsvertrag ausgehandelt hat,
da hat sie auch ein Sicherheitspaket vorgestellt, dass wir gleich erfolgreich als Überwachungspaket ähm,
umbenannt haben, was die Medien inzwischen auch sehr brav aufgreifen.
Weil da drin ist eigentlich keine Sicherheit, sondern nur mit Sicherheit mehr Überwachung und weniger Grundrechte. Und ja, wir wir haben dann irgendwie die darauffolgenden Monate ähm,
sehr laut Kampagne gemacht, um äh diese Maßnahmen zu verhindern. Aus dem einfachen Grund, weil wenn das durchgeht, wird das so der netzpolitische Supergau
Ähm wir reden hier von einer ganzen Latte von Maßnahmen, die
Vorgestellt wurden äh und inzwischen äh gibt's auch schon die dazugehörigen Gesetze, die sind seit zehnten Juli im Begutachtung,
und genau darum wird auch noch gestritten. Also die Gefahr ist, dass vor der nächsten Wahl in Österreich, die am fünfzehnten Oktober sein wird. Äh obwohl unsere Koalition schon geplatzt ist und es eigentlich äh das,
'ne Regierung, es gibt noch Minister, aber es gibt keine Koalition mehr. Ähm, und es gibt auch schon fliegende Mehrheiten im Parlament.
Trotzdem will ähm die die ehemalige Regierung äh noch all diese Verschärfungen durchbringen.
Und wir haben aber Hoffnung, dass wir ähm dieses Paket oder zumindest Teile davon noch verhindern können.
Wollen wir vielleicht mal ganz kurz ein äh Drei-Minüter-Ex-Kurs machen, was äh warum habt ihr keine Koalition mehr.
Ähm puh, also es äh war in der österreichischen Innenpolitik, die letzten Jahre schon ein bisschen zu multartig, weil,
zuerst die Sozialdemokraten sich ihres Chefs entledigt haben, Werner Fallmann wurde von Christian Kern ersetz
und ähm das war so der eine neue Start. Inzwischen hat auch die ÖVP äh ihren neuen Chef, äh, Sebastian Kurz, äh, der,
Dreißig Jahre alt ist, ehemaliger Außenminister, jüngster Außenminister ähm überhaupt, glaube ich und äh der hat die ähm.
ÖVP, umgekrempelt, ihr auch einen neuen Namen gegeben, sie heißt jetzt äh Liste Sebastian Kurz, die neue Volkspartei.
Man spricht auch nicht mehr vom Partei, sondern eigentlich ist es eine Bewegung und es pendelt halt so irgendwo zwischen ähm Orbanisierung und Macron ähm mit ein bisschen Trump
also es ist irgendwie nicht sehr fakten passiert. Ähm versucht irgendwie diesen neuen neoliberalen Anstrich sich zu geben, ist aber in vielen Dingen
eher so in Richtung Visegradstaaten ausgerichtet und bisschen ein
äh in Bürgerrechtsfragen, aber auch in Sachen Flüchtlingspolitik äh und eben auch, was so die parteiinterne.
Die angeht, hat man da eher so das Führerprinzip.
Und wie hat er das geschafft in seinen jungen Jahren.
Erst die letzte Hoffnung dieser Partei und er hat's als Bedingung gestellt, da irgendwie eine Machtübernahme äh mit Durchgriffsrecht gegenüber den äh Bünden und Landesorganisationen der Partei zu bekommen und äh hat da jetzt irgendwie
Äh starkes Durchgibsrecht, was die Listenerstellung angeht, äh alle Mandatare in Österreich müssen sowieso noch bevor sie ein Mandat bekommen, ihren Rücktritt unterschreiben
und da gibt's einfach einen hohen Kadergehorsam, das ist zum Teil auch bei der SPÖ so, also da darf man die Volkspartei nicht singulär sehen,
das das freie Mandat, was in Österreich in der Verfassung steht ist leider viel zu oft nur Theorie
äh und äh ja, das das ist durchaus bedenklich, äh was was hier passiert, aber umso bedenklicher ist es, dass man irgendwie glaubt, vor einer.
Bundesweiten Wahl wär's eine gute Idee nochmal schnell die Bürgerrechte einzuschränken,
Innern, Theresa May hat das auch probiert, dass sie irgendwie am Vortag der Wahl noch aufgerufen hat, die Menschenrechte einzuschränken. Äh das ist nicht so gut für sie ausgegangen. Äh ich finde, Politiker sollten aus dem Beispiel lernen.
Okay, dann sag uns doch mal die zusammen äh Setzung des Überwachungspaketes. Also du hast gesagt, mehrere Gesetze, die jetzt seit äh Mitte Juli auch schon in der Diskussion befindlich sind.
Genau und ähm beginnen wir mal bei den Dingen, die schon durch sind, äh die schon beschlossen oder äh verhindert wurden.
Die äh letzte Folge, wo ich zu Gast war, NLP zweihundertvierzehn hieß er abstrakte Gefährder. Und äh da ging's unter anderem für eine Fußfessel, für Nichtverurteilte, also für
Gefährder und die haben wir verhindert, die gibt es nicht, da ist der Justizminister davon abgekommen.
Inzwischen beschlossen ist aber leider die Einschränkung äh der Demonstrationsfreiheit. Man darf in Österreich inzwischen Demos verbieten, wenn sie dem außenpolitischen Interesse des österreichischen Staates,
widersprechen und es gibt ein neues äh.
Delikt für sogenannte staatsfeindliche Bewegungen, da geht's um sowas wie Freeman und Staatsverweigerer. Äh das ist aber auch laut seinen eigenen Erläuterungen ein Gesinnungsstrafrecht. Also es geht hier drum, irgendwie diese Ideologie
Der Leute, die den Staat nicht anerkennen, meistens wegen irgendwelcher irrsinniger Verschwörungstheorien, dem einen Riegel vorzuschieben,
obwohl diese ganzen Verschwörungstheoretiker, die da den Staat nicht anerkennen zum Großteil in Österreich inzwischen schon hinter Schloss und Riegel sind wegen bestehender Gesetze, nicht wegen dieser neuen Straftatbestimmung, die man erst eingeführt hat,
Die drei Themen sind abgeschlossen, neun Themen sind noch so irgendwie am Tablet. Ähm Bundeswehr im Inneren,
Wird auch nicht mehr kommen, ist jetzt geht sich nun mal aus. Die restlichen acht üben die kämpfen wir jetzt noch.
Und das ist einerseits die Legalisierung eines Bundestrojaners in Österreich, also staatliche Spionage-Software, die es im Moment in Österreich illegal und soll zur Überwachung von WhatsApp und ähnlichen Dingen legalisiert werden.
Da sind wir stark dagegen, weil es ist zwar okay, wenn man irgendwie sagt, wir wollen WhatsApp übernachten, aber,
dass der Start anfangt zum Hacker zu werden und Schadprogramme entwickelt sicherheitslücken hortet und allgemeinen Unsicherheit unserer kritischen Infrastruktur investiert, das ist der falsche Weg.
Ähm das soll kommen, äh was
Gänzlich äh nicht diskutiert wurde äh und was für mich am wichtigsten ist, äh Netzsperren. In Österreich soll ein Gesetz äh verabschiedet werden. Das ist eine Änderung, Telekommunikationsgesetz, die es erlaubt, dass Provider.
Tarife anbieten die in Inhalte im Internet zur Vermeidung von strafrechtlich relevanten Handlungen.
Sperren.
Sprich, hier kann man dann äh DNS oder auch IP-Sperren einrichten äh und der Provider soll auf einmal Richter werden und entscheiden, was strafrechtlich relevant ist und das Ganze ist so geschrieben, dass es ähm.
Dann dazu führen kann, dass es vielleicht äh,
Gar keine ungefilterten Internetangebote mehr geben kann, weiß komplett der Produktgestaltung des Providers überlassen ist. Das ist natürlich eine hundertachtzig Grad Abkehr vom Prinzip
der Netzneutralität und ist auch nicht mit der EU-Verordnung zu Netzautralität konform.
Äh sag mal, du hast gesagt, der Provider kann Tarife anbieten. Also ist das irgendwie so äh boomen sie jetzt Magenta Terrorfrei oder ähm.
Ja, so ungefähr.
Also das ist die Idee dahinter, also die die es gibt da irgendwie so zwei äh treibende Kräfte, einerseits es gibt so äh Jugend-und Virenschutzfilter, die,
in Österreich und da stückt eine sehr starke Lobby dahinter, weil äh einerseits äh Tim Mobile äh Österreich, der sehr stark dahinter ist und dann,
der Hersteller dieser Filtersoftware, der äh Kompass Verlag äh einer der best vernetzten Organisationen in Österreich ist, die da auch seit Jahren sehr,
äh lobiiert haben an allen Ebenen. Ähm und die zweite Gruppe sind äh auch wiederum Telekom-Provider, die äh aufgrund der Rechtslage. Es gab ein EuGH-Urteil, das Provider,
zu zwingt, dass sie urheberrechtlich äh äh es ist strafrechtlich relevante Urüberrechtsverletzungen sperren müssen.
Dazu gibt's aber kein Gesetz und das führt dazu, dass Provider gerade die ganze Zeit äh eine einstweilige Verfügung vor Gericht kassieren, was die Geld kostet, deswegen wollen die Gesetze dazu haben.
An die Telekom-Industrie sozusagen sehr stark dahinter, diese Netzsperren zu bekommen und äh die sind die Interessensträger dahinter, wie gesagt
Diskutiert wurde das nicht in der letzten Folge findet ihr das nicht, weil die Regierung nichts hat anklingen lassen, dass sie Netzsperren einführen will
das Ganze hat in einem Sicherheitspaket oder Überwachungspaket auch nichts zu suchen, ähm weil hier geht's ja eher um die Einschränkung der Meinungsfreiheit
Äh und äh trotzdem will man das alles durchboxen und äh wie gesagt, äh ist das ist höchstgradig äh EU-Widrig, weil du darfst zwar aufgrund der EU-Verordnung
Gesetze machen national, die einzelne Websites sperren. Ein Gericht kann auch Website sperren, das
kann beides dazu führen, dass der Provider tätig werden muss. Aber was die jetzt hier probieren, ist national ein Gesetz zu machen, das Tarife erlaubt, die das EU-Gesetz verbietet.
Und das kann nicht sein, dass EU-Recht steht immer über nationalem Recht und ähm wir tun gerade alles, um irgendwie zu verhindern, dass Österreich die,
EU Netzzeutralite aushebelt, das ist für mich natürlich auch Schal ein Ehrensache.
Stimmt. Das war der der zweite, also Staatstrainer, Netzsperren, was haben wir als Drittes?
Genau ähm.
Es soll äh Wiederüberwachung verstärkt werden. Also sprich es soll die Möglichkeit geben, das mit einfachen Bescheid, also auf Behördenweg ähm zum Beispiel die österreichischen Bundesbahnen oder.
Auch die Wiener Linien, die Verkehrsbetriebe,
eine zwei wöchentliche Vorratsdatenspeicherung von allen Videokameras aufzeichnen müssen und die an die Strafverfolgungsbehörden abliefern müssen
Äh und äh das ist auch eine Form von vorherzarten Speicherung, die wir nicht gut heißen,
war davon natürlich auch. Äh da gibt's äh keine verpflichtende geographische Einschränkung. Ähm sehr viele Menschen betroffen sein können,
und des Datenschutzrechts sieht aus guten Grund, da eine Abwägung vor, dass man je nach Bedarfsfall eben zum Beispiel in Österreich gerade nur so achtundvierzig bis zweiundsiebzig Stunden dieser Dinge speichert und A zum Beispiel nicht automatisch an die Strafverfolgungsbehörden
weiterleitet. Ähm ähnlich äh eklapptant ist die Einführung einer Kennzeichenerfassung
Also auf allen österreichischen Straßen soll,
das Kennzeichen der Lenker, Farbe, Typ und Modell des Autos erhoben werden und das Ganze wird dann in einer ähm.
Bei dem Betreiber der Autobahnen in Österreich vorgehalten und kann aber vom Innenministerium jederzeit abgerufen werden.
Äh für fünf Jahre gespeichert werden. Und.
Du hast gesagt, fahr der Fahrertyp.
Ähm das Fahrzeugtyp. Äh äh es wird ein Bild, also die, das Kennzeichen wird erfasst und äh ausgewertet. Äh ein Bild äh das sollte der Lenkerin,
und dann paar Daten über das Fahrzeug. Also es wird auch äh äh Modelltyp und Farbe sind, glaube ich, im Gesetz definiert, die auch erhoben werden. Das heißt, du hast da eine schöne Datenbank, wo du genau Bewegungsprofile machen kannst. Wer hat sich wo bewegt
ähm nach welcher Art von Fahrzeug wird vielleicht gerade gesucht oder kennen wir den Lenker oder die Lenkerin? Ähm.
Lange sollen die Sachen gespeichert werden.
Die werden beim.
Ähm Autobahnbetreiber mal vorgehalten und können aber auf einfaches Verlangen, also ohne, dass da irgendein Rechtsschutz äh vorgesehen wird, wehe ja da Rechter noch äh Rechtsschutzbeauftragter, wenn die Daten mal gespeichert werden, können sie sofort auch bei den Strafverfolgungsbehörden abgefragt werden und
dort können sie bis zu fünf Jahre lang äh in der Analyse oder Gefährderdatenbank des Staatsschutzgesetzes aufbewahrt werden. Das heißt, wir haben alle Daten
und die Datenschutzrechtlichen äh Voraussetzungen um eine komplettes Bewegungsprofil von allen Autobewegungen auf Österreich Straßen zu machen.
Vor allem die Personenbewegung ja auch noch, ne? Also wenn man mal jetzt äh an dieser Stelle kurz daran denkt,
die Gesichtserkennung, die automatisierte Gesichtserkennung in Videoaufzeichnungen ja gerade in Berlin am Bahnhof Südkreuz schon äh in Erprobungs äh in in der Erprobungsphase ist, ja?
Dann kann man sich ungefähr vorstellen, was das hier bedeutet, ne? Also die die Düsen, du hast alle Fahrzeuge ähm irgendwie so roter Golfkennzeichen so und so mit Linus Neumann am Steuer. Ähm.
Das ist echt, also das will man wirklich nicht haben, ne? Also das, das ist dann wirklich eine die Datenerfassung, die wir,
der wir online schon die ganze Zeit unschönerweise,
ausgesetzt sind, ne? Also irgendwie äh euer Browser schickt ja dem Heada mit, was für ein ähm für einen Betriebssystem und Browservariante das ist, ne? Da ist es dann, was weiß ich, ein,
Veralteter Firefolks auf einem Windows XP hat sich eingeloggt als Linus Neumann und hier wäre es eben bei welcher Webseite und hier wäre es eben.
Das Fahrzeug und der Kennzeichentyp, das ist schon echt also da kannst du dann am Ende auch nicht mehr viel mehr überwachen, ne?
Ja, also ich meine, ich glaube, den Fantasien sind ja keine Grenzen gesetzt. Unser Innenminister ähm der sich wirklich bemüht, in diesen Dingen.
Auch schon äh klar angekündigt, so also Gesichtserkennung, ja, unbedingt wollen wir massiv investieren. Am Flughafen in Schwäche, in Wien ist gerade das Pilotprojekt am Laufen, da wird massiv Geld invest,
und auch bei der vorhergenannten Videoüberwachung da ist er erstaunlich ehrlich und sagt ja klar, wir wollen da automatische Erkennung von Gefahren und von Gesichtern und ähm,
da ist halt wirklich die Idee, ähm mehr Kompetenzen, mehr Daten, größerer Heuhaufen wird uns schon irgendwann sicherer machen.
Und ähm ich meine, wir haben inzwischen sogar ehemalige Innenminister in Österreich, die unserem aktuellen Innenminister Sobotka äh ein falsches Amtsverständnis vorwerfen und sagen
Das, was der hier tut, äh, entspricht nicht den Anforderungen eines Innenministers, der sich auch um Bürgerrechte kümmern sollte.
Das haben wir in Deutschland natürlich auch so eine, also das ehemalige Innenminister äh zu Besinnung kommen Deutschland immer sehr gut zu verfolgen. Äh Gerd Baum, ne, der äh zu ganz anderen Zeiten
in Münster war, ist es in Deutschland tatsächliche äh Bedrohungen gab und der heute einer der ja aktivsten äh äh,
Ja, Grundrechtsbefürworter ist ähm.
Ja, ich.
Euch folgen sollte.
Das äh äh es ist immer besonders besonders, sondern ich meine, die Liste an Kritikern ist jetzt schon lang und wir haben noch gar nicht äh die Begutachtung erwähnt, aber auch der Präsident des Verfassungsgerichtshofs und Präsident der äh Rechtsanwaltskammer haben auch schon gesagt,
Geht hier alles überhaupt nicht und reden von DDR und Überwachungsstaat.
Also die Tendenz wird auch klar benannt von Leuten, denen man jetzt nicht so wie uns irgendwie unterstellen könnte, dass sie, dass sie sich zu sehr um den Datenschutz kümmern.
Ähm und äh das Problem ist halt, es geht trotzdem noch als Wahlkampfthema durch. Das ist so ein bisschen bedenklich, also.
Und ich glaub bei den bei den konservativen vielleicht noch irgendwie wenn wirklich subjektive Sicherheit.
Ein Argument ist nicht mehr mehr objektive Sicherheit. Sie tun ja gar nicht mal mehr so, als würde uns das wirklich sicherer machen, sondern es geht nur noch um Bauchgefühl.
Aber dass man dann ja auch noch glaubt, damit irgendwie punkten zu können als Koalitionspartner das mitzutragen, das erschließt sich mir nicht. Aber gut, ähm, kommen wir.
Ist bei bei vier von acht. Wenn ich richtig mitgezählt.
Genau, machen wir weiter.
Also jetzt kommt meine Kreativität langsam an ihre Grenzen.
Genau. Ähm, nächster Punkt ist der Lauschangriff im Auto.
Wir bleiben im Straßenverkehr und zwar ist es so, dass man in Österreich heute schon irgendwie Autos verwanzen kann, aber erst ab einem Strafrahmen von zehn Jahren.
Ist sehr hoch, aber ein Auto ist ja auch irgendwie so ähnlich wie eine Wohnung, da ist man in einem geschützten Bereich. Man führt,
Gespräche, die jetzt nicht so über Telefon vermittelt sind, wo man sie vielleicht eher zurückhält, sondern man sieht sich in die Augen, es ist ein persönliches Gespräch. Und deswegen sind die zehn Jahre Strafrahmen auch ganz gerechtfertigt, die sollen jetzt gesenkt werden.
Ein Jahr. Also auf,
Zehntel davon und äh das führt dann zu skurrilen Situationen, dass du wegen Bagatelldelikten schon im Auto überwachen kannst, aber wenn du dich wieder auf die Autohaube äh draufsetzt, draußen,
dann geht's nur noch für sehr schwere Straftaten. Es entspricht einfach nicht dem.
Charakter dieses Gesprächs und den daraus abzuleitenden Grundrechtsschutz durch die Verhältnismäßigkeit.
Da da will man einfach verschärfen, auch ohne dass es in den letzten Jahr irgendwelche Fälle gab und wir haben uns die Berichte angeschaut, die äh.
Irgendwie indizieren würden, dass man das gebraucht hätte, dass so. Wir hätten da jemanden überwachen wollen und durften nicht, nein, soll ich nicht mal so anekdotische Belege gibt es dafür,
dass das geholfen hätte. Ähm ja, dann ähnlich äh aus dem aus der Luft gegriffen, ähm Imsi-Ketcher sollen legalisiert werden.
Im Seeketcher, das kannst du wahrscheinlich noch besser erklären als ich, äh, sind halt so Überwachungstechnologien, wo du ohne Mithilfe des Mobilfunkbetreibers Handys überwachen kannst, also Gesprächsinhalte und auch Datenverbindungen, SMS, ab
äh hören kannst. Das lustige ist, das Gesetz erlaubt Insecatcher zu Lokalisierung von äh Verdächtigen und Zielpersonen.
Was irgendwie halt nicht die reale, die reale Funktionsumfang ist, ein Imse-Ketchuer äh den verwendest du, wenn du zuhören willst, vor allem beim musst du ja schon in der Nähe sein.
Dann kannst du ja auch nur in näheren Umfeld näher lokalisieren. Also das scheint uns auch irgendwie nicht ganz schlüssig.
Okay, vielleicht kurzer X kurz neben sie Ketchup ist äh im Prinzip eine.
Eine gefälschte Mobilfunkzelle,
'ne Mobilfunkzelle sagte ich bin die Zelle so und so
und mit mir kannst du dich verbinden, wenn du dich mit mit dem Netz verbinden möchtest, von dem Netz der deutschen Telekom oder so
ja ähm man könnte sich das so vorstellen wie äh also die Analogie eines WLANs äh dass man einfach ähm konzeptioniert
hilft da eigentlich sehr gut, ja? Also es gibt natürlich eine Reihe anderer Sicherheitsmaßnahmen und so, aber wenn ihr jetzt einen einen WLAN konfurieren würdet und würdet das, äh was weiß ich, Telekom nennen, dann würden äh die,
Die Geräte, die schon mal konfiguriert wurden im Telekom-Hotspot zu sein, sich auch mit eurem WLAN verbinden, ja? Damit kann man übrigens auch äh sehr viel Spaß haben, der wahrscheinlich nicht legal ist. Ähm.
Sowas machten Imsi-Ketcher. Und jetzt ist die Frage, welche Dienstleistung, welche Dienste er dann
zur Verfügung stellt. Ähm! Beispielsweise kann er also einfach sagen, okay, du bist jetzt mit dem Netz verbunden, wir können dir hier Service bereitstellen, ausgehende Anrufe sind da ein leicht,
eingehende Anrufe sind natürlich schwieriger, weil das Telefon in dem Moment nicht mehr mit seinem wirklichen Netz verbunden ist. Ähm also man kann Service bereitstellen und man kann vor allem eines machen,
man kann auf Verschlüsselung verzichten. Und ähm.
Das ist etwas, was äh normalerweise äh dass das Mobilfunknetz ja tut und somit wäre es ein Imsi-Ketcher auch eine Möglichkeit.
Ähm Telefone, Telefonate abzuhören, die einem unter anderen Umständen.
Mit einem rein passiven Empfang unter Umständen
nicht zugänglich wären. Das Ganze teilt sich dann nochmal in die zwei G drei G und vier G Netze, wo jeweils unterschiedliche Sicherheitsvorkehrungen, unterschiedliche ähm Bedingungen für
das Mobiltelefon,
Und für die Möglichkeiten mit diesem abzuhören oder sonstiges äh ergeben. Das wird ein bisschen äh detailliert. Ich würde sagen, in den Shownotes suche ich da nochmal ein paar Beispiele raus. Unter anderem habe ich da auch mal beim.
CC Camp zweitausendfünfzehn äh darüber gesprochen, weil ich mich ein paar Jahre äh,
Intensiver mit so ihm sie Ketchern auseinandergesetzt habe und mit dem Erkennen und verteidigen dagegen. Ähm.
Entscheidend ist aber auch, dass ein Imsy-Ketchup tatsächlich zur Lokalisierung relativ gut geeignet ist. Also ähm es ist immer das Beispiel, was äh Befürworter von Imsi-Catchern benennen, dass sie damit
Selbstmörder im Wald finden, ne? Also ähm du hast ja äh
du hast irgendjemand, der oder droht jetzt etwas zu tun? Muss ja nicht unbedingt sein, dass er kann ja auch jemand anderem etwas Böses antun wollen und dass du damit eine Lokalisierung.
Vornehmen kannst, wenn die Person nichts sagt, wo sie ist,
dann loggst du quasi das Telefon in diesen Imsi-Ketcher, hast 'ne Richtantenne dran und lokalisierst damit dieses Gerät. Mir sind nur leider tatsächlich aus der freien Wildbahn wenige Fälle bekannt, wo das tatsächlich mal der Fall war.
Ähm viel mehr Fälle sind bekannt bei,
den US-Drohnen, die ja mit Hilfe von Imsekern dann eben die letzten
metergenauigkeit erlangen. Da ist das also so, du hast vielleicht eine grobe Ahnung, wo
sich deine Zielperson befindet und dann fliegst du mit mir im Seeketcher rum und ähm lässt sich dieses Telefon authentifizieren,
an deinem Insi-Catcher und dann kannst du.
Tatsächlich äh das Telefon dazu bringen ähm dauerhaft zu senden, nennt sich Silent Call. Äh das heißt, du versetzt dieses Telefon in ein.
Äh in einen Modus, wo es dauerhaft äh Signale imitiert, ohne dass das Telefon selber.
Dass dem Nutzer anzeigt, dass gerade irgendetwas los ist und dann fliegst du
mit deinen Richtanten äh quasi in Richtung dieses Funksignales und fliegst also quasi im Kreis,
das Ziel heroben und kannst es so äh lokalisieren, weil du eben siehst, äh.
Dass deine Richtantenne immer dahin zeigt, wo das Signal äh am stärksten ist, ja? Äh also Imsi-Ketcher kann zur Lokalisierung genutzt werden und ich würde sogar vorsichtig das Argument bringen, dass das ähm heutzutage.
Tatsächlich noch die sinnvollste Anwendung für einen Imsy-Catcher ist. Unter der Voraussetzung, dass du damit im eigenen Lande operierst, ja? Weil abhören äh kannst du ja ohnehin,
Ähm und zwar einfacher, wenn du dir eine, wenn du nämlich mit richterlicher Anordnung,
Zum äh Mobilfunkanbieter gehst, als wenn du jetzt damit mit ihm sie ketcher herumhampelst. Die Frage ist nur, äh warum würdest du jemanden lokalisieren wollen.
Und die Legende oder der das Anwendungsbeispiel, was da eben häufig äh vorgetragen wird, äh eben
Menschen lokalisieren zu wollen, die androhen, sich selbst etwas zu tun, ist ein sehr seltenes Beispiel
der fallen andere Beispiele sehr viel besser ein und die Forschung der zu diesem Bereich in den USA zeigt auch dass es eben da viel mehr im,
im Rahmen der äh Strafverfolgung äh stattfindet.
Also da würden wir uns halt auch noch wünschen. Ähm es kann schon sein, dass diese Maßnahme sinnvoll ist, dann dann wird's ja auch die Belege dafür geben, wenn wenn man sie wirklich braucht, dann ist es ja gut, wenn die Legalisierung dafür geschaffen wird.
Aber da muss die Legalisierung auch der Realität entsprechen. Ähm also die zweite Forderung wäre, dass man dann irgendwie.
Sicherstellt, dass diese Ketchup auch nur.
Lokalisierung können, weil dem einzelnen Polizisten, der braucht schon sehr viel.
Zurückhaltung, wenn er jetzt irgendwie gerade wirklich jemanden sucht und er weiß, da müsst ihr nur auf den Knopf drücken und dann könnte er zuhören.
Dass er das dann nicht tut äh und ähm entweder das Gesetz äh muss muss alles erlauben, was das Gerät kann oder das Gerät muss technisch so eingeschränkt sein, dass es nur das kann, was das Gesetz erlaubt, aber da darf's keine Diskrepanz geben,
Aus unserer Sicht, da muss man einfach ähm die richtigen Safe Guards setzen in der Praxis.
Also worauf sie worauf man äh an der Stelle tatsächlich achten könnte, ist ähm die SC You hat damit, wenn ich das Recht im Sinne.
Auch noch äh rechtlich ganz entscheidende Erfolge gehabt. Ähm dieser Angriff erscheint nicht
so invasiv zu sein, ne? Also du äh aber er hat natürlich andererseits kann er unter sehr viel weniger
Also wie, wie ein vollständiges, abhörendes Telefon ist, ja? Oder wie eine Funkzellenabfrage. Ja, man könnte ja auf Anhieb argumentieren, nun äh für Abhören des Telefons, brauchst du einen richterlichen Beschluss
und ein Zugang beim beim Anbieter und damit ist das 'ne,
Ist das in Ordnung oder ist das, ist das ist das relativ invasiv, weil du alle möglichen Gespräche abhörst, ja?
Mit einem Insi-Ketcher äh könntest du in wenigen Fällen situationsbezogene Gespräche abhören, was du unter anderen Umständen äh so nicht tun würdest, ja? Also mit einem Seeketcher fährst du ja nicht einen Monat lang hinter jemandem her.
Ähm gleichzeitig könnte man sagen, dass so eine Funkzellenabfrage alle in der Funkzelle befindlichen Personen betrifft
während ein Insi-Ketchuper in der Regel gerichtet gegen eine Person eingesetzt wird. Ähm, das Gegenteil ist der Fall, der MC Ketchup wird nämlich selbst wenn er nur eine Person.
Tatsächlich catchen möchte, ähm! Auch alle anderen in seinem.
Empfangsbereich liegenden Personen in den Imsi-Ketchup,
reinziehen einmalig und diese dann Rejecten, ja? Das heißt, die äh versuchen sich mit dem Imzy-Ketchup zu verbinden ähm und dann sagt der Imsi-Ketcher, nee, du darfst hier nicht her, geh bitte wieder in eine andere Zelle.
Ähm dabei verlieren die den die Verbindung zum Mobilfunk, zu ihrem normalen Mobilfunknetz und zu ihrer ähm.
Äh damit zu damit ihre Konnektivität und das ist deswegen äh interessant, weil du ihnen damit die Möglichkeit nimmst,
Einen äh eingehenden Anruf zu bekommen und die Möglichkeit, oft die Möglichkeit nimmst, gerade bei den Location-Tracking im Seecatchern einen ausgehenden Anruf zu tätigen. Und das ist blöd, weil du ihnen damit die Möglichkeit nimmst, einen Notruf abzusetzen,
Und in den äh das hat äh rechtlich äh entscheidende.
Sequenzen gehabt bei nicht äh äh legalisiertem
Einsatz von Imsi-Ketchern in in den USA. Also ich hatte mich da mit dem ACU-Anwalt, der diese ganzen
Prozesse geführt hat aus den heiligen Gründen relativ oft unterhalten.
Und ähm also das das ist etwas, was man ja eigentlich.
Tatsächlich in in strengen rechtlichen Grenzen haben möchte und weil die wenigsten Leute wissen wie so ein Imsi-Ketchup tatsächlich genau funktioniert. Hm, äh vergessen wird da häufig.
Wenn da die Details des Einsatzes außer acht gelassen und das Komplexeste ist eigentlich bei einem eingehender Anrufe.
Zu ermöglichen. Deswegen ist das auch in der Regel nicht der Fall. Und damit deswegen ist das auch eine relativ invasive Angelegenheit, auch wenn sie zu den,
gezielten gehört, die damit natürlich erstmal nicht so.
Als nicht so krass zu beurteilen sind wie eine vollständige Telekommunikationsüberwachung ähm und äh oder wie eine Funktion äh Abfrage.
Ja, ist doch ganz spannend, weil äh eine der Verteidigungsstrategien der relevanten Ministerien Innenjusti
Innen- und Justizministerium ist auch gerade,
aber es geht ja doch gar nicht um Massenüberwachung und sie reden da aber nur über den Bundestrojaner.
Ähm und äh natürlich gibt's eine Massenüberwachung bei der Kennzeichenerfassung und wir würden auch sagen bei der Videoüberwachung und noch bei einem der weiteren Themen, äh, die wir, die wir noch vor uns haben. Ich würde mal weitermachen, weil das passt grad gut dazu. Ähm.
Unter dem Titel Vorratsdatenspeicherung zwei Punkt null soll Quickfreeze eingeführt werden und da muss man auch kurz die Begriffe unterscheiden.
Vorratshaltenspeicherung kennen wir glaube ich alle, die anlasslose Massenüberwachung von allen äh von Mieterdaten, von Anrufen, SMS, E-Mails und ähm ja, IP-Adressen, beziehungsweise Internetverbindungen in manchen Ländern.
Und davon reden wir hier nicht, wir reden von Quickfreeze, das ist eine Anlassbezogene Speicherung
äh wo äh zuerst mal von niemandem was gespeichert wird, außer ein Staatsanwalt, geht zum Telekomprovider und sagt, äh, mit sehr niedrigen Hürden aber,
Bitte von dieser Person
Von jetzt an nichts mehr löschen. Für ein Jahr lang werden die Daten dann vom Provider gespeichert und erst mit richterlicher Anordnung kann die Strafverfolgungsbehörde dann aber auf die Daten zugreifen,
Das wurde ja auch in Deutschland damals als die Alternative und die Grundrechtsschonende Variante von Vorratsdatenspeicherung diskutiert. Ähm.
Und äh wir sind immer noch keine Fans von der Methode, aber,
ist das viel, viel besser als eine wirkliche Vorratsdatenspeicherung, weil wir hal
hier eben nicht von der Massenüberwachung sprechen, aber
Natürlich ist dann wieder die Frage, was ist der konkrete Safecard in der Praxis? Und äh das Problem ist in einem ursprünglichen Arbeitsprogramm gab's noch so einen Safeguard, dass nämlich, wenn der Richter sagt,
nein, diese Daten kriegt ihr nicht, weil die Person wurde fälschlicherweise überwacht, ihr habt gar keine keinen Verdacht und deswegen könnt ihr auch äh dieser Person die Daten dann nicht mehr auskunften.
Dann wäre im originalen Entwurf noch vorgesehen gewesen, dass die Person informiert wird über ihre fälschliche Überwachung und ihren Grundrechtseingrif,
Das findet sich im aktuellen Gesetz, wie es jetzt vorgelegt wurde, nicht mehr
und äh das äh sehen wir als äh großes, großes Fee, ähm großen Fehler in dem Gesetz, weil damit gibt's keinerlei Anreize,
diese Maßnahme nicht tausendfach an zur Anwendung zu bringen und nicht einfach zu sagen, ja, ganze Bevölkerungsgrupp
werden jetzt mal einfach mit Quickfreeze versehen und die werden das schon nicht rausbekommen, weil der Provider darf ja auch nicht drüber reden.
Und deswegen wär's gut, wenn man hier wieder zum Originalentwurf zurückgeht und wie gesagt, Quickfees ist jetzt auch
es fehlt noch immer der Beleg dafür, wozu brauchen wir das? Wo hilft es uns? Was sind die,
und Fakten, wo es uns gefehlt hat in,
Jahren. Österreich hat ja seit zweitausendvierzehn aufgrund unserer Klage vom Höchstgericht keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung mehr.
Aber es wäre spannend, wenn Österreich das einzige Land in Europa ist, was kein,
Datenspeicherung aber dafür Quickfreeß hätte. Meines Wissens nach wehren wir das dann.
Ja, das äh soll miterwähnt werden und das letzte Thema ist die Registrierungspflicht für SIM-Karten.
Moment kann man in Österreich noch einfach zum Discounter gehen und eine SIM-Karte kaufen und die funktioniert, ohne dass man jemals seinen Ausweis hergezeigt hat
Äh und das soll verboten werden, eine Ausweispflicht beim Kauf von Wertkarten. Also Prepaid-Karten.
Und da gibt's auch extrem viele Studien von,
ähm von sogar der Telekomindustrie, die belegen, dass es keinerlei ähm Studien gäbe oder auch nur irgendwelche Nachweise, dass äh so eine SIM-Kartenregistrierung,
Der Verbrechensaufklärung oder Terrorprävention helfen würde.
Das hat auch Cecilia Marls, Malmström, als sie noch zweitausendzwölf Innenkommissarin war, gesagt und ähm da ja,
fehlt uns halt wirklich jeder Beleg und in Österreich gibt's fünf Millionen solcher anonymer SIM-Karten im Moment. Bei der Bevölkerung von acht Millionen, also auch hier kann man.
Vielleicht von einer Massenüberwachung sprechen, natürlich.
Muss man diese SIM-Kartenregistrierung dann in der Gesamtschau sehen? Also wo die glaube ich in der Praxis dann viel hilft, ist zum Beispiel bei Funkzellenabfragen, dass man dann halt einfacher zuordnen kann,
wem gehört gerade dieses Telefon, was bei der Demonstration war und nachdem das auch nicht für bestehende SIM-Karten ist, äh,
Ist es äh definitiv eher in die Zukunft gerichtet.
Und man kann immer noch eine Sympathie aus dem Ausland verwenden oder eben wenn's um SMS geht, anonyme Messenger-Dienste, um die Binanzen ein bisschen zu entgehen, also mit ein bisschen krimineller Energie ist man da auch schnell außen vor.
Aber das ist sozusagen die letzte Maßnahme, die jetzt auch noch gefordert wird.
Also Staatstrojaner. Haben wir in Deutschland auch Netzsperren, haben wir nach meiner Kenntnis nicht.
Videoüberwachung, äh Videoüberwachungsvorratsdaten,
weiß ich gar nicht so genau, ähm haben wir aber nach meiner Kenntnis nicht
Kennzeichen Erfassung in dem Ausmaß nicht. Wir haben aber natürlich schon überall die Stationen dafür stehen. Ähm,
glaube, die findet grade noch so im halblegalen Rahmen statt
angeblich die Toll-Collect-Stationen machen das ja nicht oder speichern nicht so lange,
Ähm es steht aber irgendwie, wenn man hier von Berlin nach Polen fährt, fährt auf, steht auf jeden Fall so ein Ding.
Der Lauschangriff im Auto ist ja, glaube ich, eher so eine Vorbereitung auf das Auto der Zukunft.
Im Seeketcher-Einsatz ist in Deutschland glaube ich, also wird ist auf jeden Fall Gang und Gäbe, äh beziehungsweise findet selten statt, aber findet statt.
Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben wir ähm allerdings ja gerade ausgesetzt mal wieder und die Registrierungspflicht für SIM-Karten haben wir auch. Ich glaube so äh kann man das gerade mal.
Äh spontan aus meiner Erinnerung abrufen. Und bei euch wird das jetzt alles.
Acht eins in den Gesetzen diskutiert oder wird das jetzt wenigstens mal komplett auf die Waage geworfen?
Also das Ganze ist ein Paket. Ähm wir reden von
Äh im Grunde fünf Gesetzen, äh die davon betroffen sind, aufgeteilt auf zwei Begutachtungsverfahren, weil Justiz und Innenministerium hier vorgelegt haben
Äh insgesamt ist das Sicherheitspolizeigesetz, Telekommunikationsgesetz, Strafprozessordnung und dann auch noch zwei Autobahnmautgesetze
Äh und äh all diese Maßnahmen wurden eben am zehnten Juli vor,
das heißt, jetzt haben wir endlich mal am Tisch liegen, was konkret geplant ist.
Seitdem gibt's massiven Protest. Es.
Wir haben da ja schon reagiert, wir haben irgendwie innerhalb von glaube ich achtundvierzig Stunden wieder mal in die
Küste gegriffen. Es ist also meine Hobby kreative Kampagnen zu machen. Und äh eine eine parlamentarische Begutachtung in Österreich funktioniert so, dass sich ähm
Alle äußern können mit einer Stellungnahme, die man einfach per E-Mail an das Parlament und an das Ministerium schickt
Und äh wir haben dann einfach auf Überwachungspaket AT ein schönes Tool gebaut, wo man einfach sagen kann, ich bin gegen Bundestrojaner, gegen Netzsperren
und dann klickt man so an, wo man dagegen ist und klickt eine einen Vorschlag für eine Stellungnahme.
Irgendwie noch ein paar Daten an und stimmt der Veröffentlichung auf dem,
zu, die ist nämlich zumindest der Name, muss veröffentlicht werden
dann ist man fertig und hat äh sich in einem parlamentarischen Begutachtungsprozess mit seiner Stellungnahme geäußert und seiner Stimme Gehör verschafft.
Das haben wir online gestellt und dann äh ja, haben das sehr viele Leute sehr toll gefunden. Wir stehen jetzt gerade
äh unter achttausend Stellungnahmen äh und das hat die Regierung ordentlich ins Schwitzen gebracht
und ähm nach ähm zwei Wochen hat die SPÖ, so die Sozialdemokratie in Österreich angefangen zurückzurudern. Und ähm.
Das aber nach einer bekannten Dramaturgie.
Wer sich erinnert, das Staatsschutzgesetz die letzte große Ausweitung von Überwachungsgesetzen, haben sie das genau gleich gemacht. Wir kennen diesen.
Diesen Scherz schon langsam. Sie haben nämlich den grundrechtsfreundlichen Politiker nach vorne geschickt, der gemeint hat, nein, das geht alles überhaupt gar nicht und wir werden dem keinesfalls zustimmen, die große Entwarnung.
Dann kam der Club Obmann, also der Chef der Parlamentsfraktion und hat gesagt,
Ja, also einem buntes Torjaner werden wir auf keinen Fall zustimmen. Wir merken schon, eine ganze Menge an Maßnahmen und,
Jetzt reden wir nur noch über den Bundestrojaner und der kommt angeblich nicht
äh und um dann äh hat sich äh zwei Tage später unser Kanzler auch von der.
Äh im Rahmen eines Kasernenbesuches lustigerweise auch wieder geäußert und gesagt, na ja, äh Sicherheit darf kein Wahlkampfthema werden.
Und äh sich aber überhaupt nicht positioniert, ob man dem jetzt zustimmen wird oder nicht. Seitdem gibt's aber so den Glauben in Österreich. Wir haben das schon verhindert.
Und da darf ich zur äh Vorsicht warnen, weil das.
Kennen wir schon und es ist sehr wahrscheinlich, dass die Sozialdemokratie dem Ganzen immer noch zustimmt, dass man einfach sagt, na,
Sicherheit, das wollen wir erst recht zum Wahlkampfthema machen und deswegen ähm stimmen wir dem noch zu und vielleicht kommt kein Bundestrojaner,
aber immer noch Netzsperrenkennzeichen, Erfassung und neue Vorratsdatenspeicherung und deswegen äh ist zu Vorsicht geraten und wir haben jetzt noch bis zum einundzwanzigsten August Zeit auf der.
Ähm Website des Parlaments, sich einfach selber mit einer Stellungnahme zu äußern oder wenn man's einfach haben will auf Überwachungspaket AT, das Tool zu nutzen.
Und wenn das noch möglichst viele Leute machen, haben wir ein noch stärkeres Zeichen gesetzt und ähm,
Der Kanzler hat noch äh gesagt, diese Begutachtung ist ihm ganz wichtig und er ist gespannt auf das Ergebnis und er wird das auf jeden Fall einfließen lassen,
und wir haben jetzt schon sehr viele honorige Organisationen. Ich habe schon äh die Rechtsanwaltskammer und andere genannt, die sagen, das geht nicht,
wenn wir in der Qualität und in der Quantität das zu einer der deutlichsten Begutachtungen,
der zweiten Republik machen, dann glaube ich, dass wir diese Maßnahmen alle noch vor der Wahl verhindern können.
Im Gegenzug wenn wir das nicht tun, dann könnte es uns passieren, dass wir halt wirklich um sehr viele schlechte Gesetze umfallen.
Noch bevor gewählt wird im Oktober und das ist so gerade irgendwie das State of Play und worum's jetzt geht. Die nächst.
Jetzt habe ich aber ich äh ich erinnere mich, dass ihr Mitte Juli doch da blockiert wurdet. Da hattet ihr also was war da los? Das die diese Blockade ist wieder aufgehoben worden oder.
Nee, nee. Äh das das war sehr schön, weil ähm wie gesagt, diese Begutachtungen sind etwas.
Da beteiligen sich also das Beste, was es jemals gab, waren glaube ich äh
sechshundert oder tausendsechshundert Stellungnahmen, die überhaupt kamen und das war wirklich glaube ich Bildungsreform
Ähm wo wirklich das ganze Land gestritten hat und normalerweise wird das hingenommen, dass da eben ganz viele E-Mails ankommen. Bei uns waren's dann aber so viele, dass das gerade das Justizministerium,
einfach diese E-Mails blockiert hat und uns die schöne Fehlermeldung ähm,
als äh E-Mail Fehlermeldung zurückgeworfen hat äh und einfach keinen.
Mehr angenommen hat, äh dass,
keine realen Auswirkungen, weil das Parlament veröffentlicht, all diese Stellungnahmen zum Glück noch, die nehmen Bürgerbeteiligung ein bisschen ernster, als das Justizministerium,
und ja also es äh ist auf jeden Fall ein Problem, wenn man irgendwie glaubt. Äh wir machen ja ein Gesetz und wenn die Leute sich dann aufregen, dann machen wir einfach die Türe zu und hören nicht zu. Äh man sollte diese Kritik ernst nehmen
Weil das sind Menschen, die mit ihrem Namen äh und in den meisten Fällen dann auch wirklich mit persönlichen Stellungnahmen vieler ändern, dieser Texte. Ähm.
Sich zu Wort melden und denen sollte man Gehör geben und nicht einfach sagen äh das stört uns, das drehen wir ab.
Jut. Damit sei also nochmal aufgerufen, eine das Stellungnahmentool unter Überwachungspaket Punkt AT zu nutzen. Äh was noch können wir tun.
Ähm drüber reden, andere Leute dazu auffordern, äh das vielleicht auch zu tun. Wie gesagt, es ist wirklich so in, wenn man, wenn man nicht selber schreiben will, in zwei, drei Minuten ist man fertig mit so einer Stellungnahme.
Und äh die ist ein ein sehr starkes Zeichen äh und wenn das genügend Leute machen, ist es gut, wenn man drüber redet, ist es noch besser.
Ähm, wer in Österreich ist, der kann sich auch gerne bei unseren Vernetzungstreffen melden. Wir haben ein Kalender auf Epicenter Works und inzwischen recht viele Gruppen in den Bundesländern, wo man dazu kommen kann. Ich glaube, gerade.
Hörerinnen und Hörer dieses Podcasts werden äh sehr gern gesehene Gäste. Wer sich für Netzpolitik interessiert, äh es ist äh immer ein guter Gesprächspartner für uns und äh wer sich engagieren will, umso mehr.
Ja und ansonsten wird Leben von Spenden äh und diese Kampagne war sehr teuer und geht schon sehr lange.
Wäre auch noch toll, wenn man uns irgendwas in den Hut wirft. Ähm weil Juristenstunden sind teuer.
Aber ansonsten äh ja ich ich hoffe, dass wir das noch
Pink zu bekommen, weil es wäre schon schön, wenn wir irgendwie äh all diese Maßnahmen vor, wo du vorher gemeint hast, die haben wir in Deutschland schon, wenn wir die jetzt noch verhindern könnten. Gerade ein Bundestrojaner, weil ich glaube wirklich, da ist, dass es der falsche Weg, was wir bräuchten, wer,
'ne internationale Ächtung von staatlichen Hacking und von dieser Art von Horten, von Sicherheitslücken, äh, das wäre die bessere Richtung, wenn dies gehen sollte.
Äh ich habe gesehen, dass da äh die Stellungnahme, die ich ja auch erst kürzlich in äh Deutschland abgegeben habe, auch nochmal in Österreich.
Darauf verwiesen wurde.
Ähm vielleicht äh äh sind da ja die Leute den Argumenten zugänglich. Ansonsten äh hast du ja auch bessere äh äh bessere Track Records als ich im im Weg klagen vor Verfassungsgerichten.
Ja, ja, muss man, muss man auch äh die, die das klagen ist wirklich immer nur der letzte Weg, weil das dauert verdammt lang und ich.
Trau dann doch immer ein bisschen auf die Parlamente, trotz allem und ich hoffe irgendwie, dass wir das eher noch äh in der Demokratie gelöst bekommen, anstatt dann wieder vors Gericht zu müssen. Ähm.
Aber die Stellungnahme zum Bundestrojaner vom CTC war wahnsinnig gut, die kann man nur äh die kann man gar nicht genügend loben.
Ähm.
Wir haben aber gerade schon über Gerichte gesprochen und ich würde sagen, das nutzen wir doch jetzt mal hier für eine äußerst äh elegante Überleitung.
Zum EuGH. Der hat nämlich auch äh wieder äh ein Gericht Kredenz, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Ja ähm wir wir äh haben positive Nachrichten zu vermelden, nämlich es gibt ein EuGH-Urteil gegen das Kanada, PNA Abkommen.
PNA, Passenger nehmen Record, äh, steht für Fluggastdatenabkommen, sprich da werden,
die Daten von Fluggästen mit Kanada ausgetauscht und das Ganze ist eine Maßnahme der Terrorabwehr
Derartige Fluggastdatenabkommen gibt es mit mehreren Ländern, mit äh den USA natürlich mit Mexiko, unter anderem und äh das war ein sehr klares Urteil gegen diese Art von Vorratsdatenspeicherung von Reisebewegungen
und die Forderungen werden auch schon laut von Alexander Sander, dem Chef der digitalen Gesellschaft, der ja schon ewig lange dieses PNA-Thema verfolgt.
John McNemie, dem ähm Geschäftsführer von von Idri, von European Digital Rights, äh, da eben jetzt die Konsequenzen rauszuziehen und zu sagen
Die anderen Fluggastdatenabkommen für den Austausch von solchen Daten mit den USA, mit Mexiko, die müssen auch alle gekippt werden und,
vor allem die Richtlinie, die wir geschaffen haben für eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung von äh Flugastar,
innerhalb Europas, wo jeder Staat so ein Piernaruswertungssystem bauen soll.
Die gehört jetzt aufgehoben, weil äh es ist jetzt das xte Mal, dass Gerichte sagen.
Vorratsdatenspeicherung geht nicht, geht wirklich nicht, geht nicht mit dem Grundrechten zusammen und irgendwann sollten die Staaten vielleicht darauf hören,
Weil das Spiel wird irgendwie äh bisschen repetitiv mit der Zeit.
Das repetitive Spiel der Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist aber noch nicht ganz vorbei, äh denn wenn ich mich nicht täusche, äh haben wir jetzt einen neuen Anlauf zur Vorzeitenspeicherung auf EU-Ebene.
Ja, ihr habt das bewusst so formuliert,
Natürlich haben die Politiker nicht gelernt, ähm wie vor wenigen Tagen rauskam, äh ist es so, dass in äh der EU gerade neue Versuche unternommen werden, eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung einzuführen
Also man hört gerade nicht auf die Gerichte, sondern äh in diesem Fall ist es der äh Rat, also sprich die achtundzwanzig EU-Mitgliedsstaaten, vor allem gerade unter der,
Istischen Ratspräsidentschaft, die versuchen ähm auszuloten, wie man eine neue Vorratsdatenspeicherung machen kann,
das Ganze ist ein bissel getriggert durch die E-Privacy-Verordnung,
die die eine Kannbestimmung zu dem Thema hat und es ist natürlich fragwürdig,
rechtlich überhaupt zulässig ist, weil es gibt jetzt schon so viele Urteile vom EuGH, die,
das originale Urteil von zweitausendvierzehn bestätigt haben und im Parlament ist man hier auch bisschen problembewusster und im Parlament gäbe es
hoffe ich, im Moment keine Mehrheit für eine neue Vorratsdatenspeicherung, aber die EU-Mitgliedsstaaten sind hier leider nicht zu lernfähig und deswegen gilt's ein Augen.
Merkt drauf zu haben, da könnte nochmal etwas kommen und,
Gerade auch eben in Deutschland, wo es gerade keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung gibt, äh es es wäre jetzt wirklich mal konsequent, wenn man sagt, wir überlegen uns was Neues. Vor allem es gibt ja keinen Beleg, wieso Vorratsdatenspeicherung uns
sicherer macht, wo wo die irgendwo Verbrechensaufklärung oder Terrorprävention befördert hätte, wo sie gefehlt hat in den in den Staaten, wo sie aufgehoben wurde.
Ein bisschen mehr objektiv auf dieses Sicherheitsthema zuzugehen, dass das ist unausweichlich meiner Meinung nach. Also,
sind wir uns halt ewig im Kreis und ja. Ja.
Ja
Wer sich äh nicht mehr ewig im Kreis dreht, sondern tatsächlich massiv voranschreitet, äh ist die Türkei. Ja? Also da haben wir.
Da kann man nicht von von in dem Kreis drehen reden,
Ein Thema, was sich hier relativ früh äh im Logbuch mit aufgenommen habe äh war die äh Verhaftung mehrerer Menschenrechtsaktivisten in,
Istanbul nämlich insgesamt zehn, äh die jetzt auch unter dem Hashtag wie Istanbul Tenn, also Istanbul eins null. Ähm.
Bekannter werden. Ähm anfangs äh also warum wir das Thema nur zögernd aufgenommen haben, weil man war anfangs noch voller Hoffnung.
Dass äh die stille Diplomatie vielleicht in der Lage wäre, äh die Leute wieder frei zu bekommen, aber äh am achtzehnten Juli wurde dann ein
Gerichtsverfahren gegen sie eröffnet und sie wurden in die Untersuchungshaft überführt, die ja in,
der Türkei etwas strafferen Regeln unterliegt
Äh als in Deutschland und da sehr viel ähm sehr viel mehr Willkür ermöglicht. Und ähm in Deutschland und Schweden hat die Medienarbeit jetzt äh losge
seit einiger Zeit läuft sie da. Wir haben äh das Thema war dann auch äh ich glaube einen Tag ähm so auf allen
Startseiten in Deutschland, Tagesschau und Spiegel und so weiter.
Und ähm diese Woche wurde jetzt der Einspruch gegen die Untersuchungshaft abgelehnt, das heißt.
Acht der zehn Menschenrechtlerin bleiben in Haft. Äh zwei.
Äh wurden auf Kortion freigelassen und äh die äh,
diese Acht, die verbleibenden acht sind jetzt inzwischen in Selivri, dem größten Gefängnis äh Europas außerhalb von Istanbul etwa siebzig Kilometer. Ähm.
Ali Günal, Peter und Weli sind dabei sogar in Einzelhaft und was man darüber äh liest, ist irgendwie auch nicht so geil. Die Zellen sind wohl nicht die schönsten.
Aber wenn sie die sauberer machen wollen, äh müssen sie das selber machen und können im Gefängnis dafür äh Putzmittel kaufen. Also das sind äh türkische Haftbedingungen.
Ähm ein Anwaltsbesuch per Woche und der darf eine Stunde dauern.
Ähm also völlig äh skurrile ähm Bedingungen da, ähm.
Ideal Eser werden unter anderem dann friedliche, legale Menschenrechtsaktivitäten zur Last gelegt, die unter anderem
von Amnesty durchgeführt wurden, bevor die Amtszeit überhaupt begonnen hat, ja? Also das heißt, wir haben hier jetzt inzwischen sehr offenes Vorgehen,
gegen freie Meinungsäußerung, gegen den friedlichen Einsatz für Menschenrechte, die der hier als Verbrechen gewertet wir.
Damit also ein ganz klaren Angriff auf diese unabhängige internationale Menschenrechtsorganisation es ist
Bei Amnesty noch nie vorgekommen, dass zwei ähm herausragende
Figuren in einem Land gleichzeitig im im Knast sind, ja? Also einmal die Direktorin Idele Esa und Tana Killi, beides, äh, wichtige Personen bei Amnesty,
Türkei ähm das ist also in der Geschichte von Amnesty äh auch ein Novum, dass direkt zwei Personen da eingeknastet sind für uns in Deutschland natürlich dann äh entscheidend Peter Steudner.
Der da jetzt auch seinen Monat in türkischer Haft voll hat dafür dass er da bei einem Digitaltraining weggeknastet wurde und man fragt sich wirklich was da in der.
Türkei los ist.
Es gibt dazu einige Links ähm was ihr tun könnt äh um da äh laut zu werden ähm.
Natürlich ja Tweets, Postings in sozialen Netzwerken. Es gibt eine äh Fotoaktion.
Wo man also äh Bilder äh ausdrucken kann. Es gibt natürlich den Aufruf äh Amnesty zu folgen und zu teilen, Benner einzubinden. Aber es gibt auch Offline-Aktionen.
Also Plakate es gibt eine Postkartenaktion. Es ist natürlich ähm.
Relativ unwahrscheinlich in meiner Einschätzung, dass ausgerechnet eine dieser Aktionen äh da jetzt äh.
Dann die Türkei umstimmt, aber gleichzeitig äh denke ich ist jetzt auch relativ klar,
zu erkennen, dass es sich dabei äh um politische Gefangene handelt, genauso wie äh äh bei Deniz Yücel, äh die da jetzt irgendwie als äh Druckmittel gegen die äh deutsche Bundes.
Zynische Forderungen gehört, äh dass man ja einen Gefangenentausch machen könnte, dass also die die.
Terroristen, äh die die Türkei äh gefangen hält gegen die Terroristen.
Die Deutschland gefangen hält äh eingetauscht werden können, die Reden wir hier also von äh an den Putschversuchbeteiligten.
Generellen in der Türkei, also das Ganze ist relativ äh irre und ich glaube äh wenigstens durch etwas Lärm kann man da zeigen, dass dass diese, dass dieser Scheiß hier in Deutschland äh.
Ganz anders gesehen wird und dass wir natürlich fordern, dass diese Menschen da freigelassen werden und ähm.
Es ist wirklich beängstigend, weil diese Digital Security Trainings, das sind äh mehr oder weniger Kryptoparties, ja? Und das ist irgendwie, es gehört zu der großen äh Dystopie.
Äh das derartiges Engagement eben auch irgendwann mal in Deutschland ähm.
Unter Strafe fällt und deswegen ist es wichtig, da jetzt.
Den Anfängen zu wehren und dagegen vorzugehen.
Ja, das ist ein macht mich immer sprachlos inzwischen, was in der Türkei passiert und und äh ja äh.
Gut, dass wir verlinken Emnis, die äh organisiert hier wenigstens den Protest und man kann nur hoffen, dass das irgendwie dazu führt, dass man da.
Mit Druck und mit äh öffentlicher Aufmerksamkeit äh ja vielleicht diese Leute freibekommt oder zumindest halt einfach äh klar macht, dass dass sie nicht vergessen sind ähm dass es da.
Auch eine Perspektive gibt äh in irgendeiner Form. Wobei eine wirkliche Lösung äh an erscheint wirklich immer unrealistischer bei der Richtung, in die die Türkei da ab.
Dann kommen wir zu etwas kürzeren Meldungen, die äh mit denen wir der Chronistenpflicht ähm.
Äh äh irgendwie äh nachkommen. Und zwar gibt es in diesem Fall der Telekom-Router ähm ein.
Ein Urteilsspruch in in Köln, das ging relativ zügig, wenn man sich das mal überlegt. Der Telekom-Route-Ausfall ist ja erst einige Monate her.
Und es ist auch erst äh kurze Zeit her, dass da überhaupt jemand
als Verantwortlicher gefangen wurde und jetzt auch noch vor Gericht stand und dann auch äh abgeurteilt wo,
warum das in diesem Fall so schnell geht, äh, sollte einleuchten, denn,
wie ihr euch vielleicht erinnert, ging es ja gar nicht darum
Bei den Telekom-Routern den Ausfall herbeizuführen. Ich hatte das ja äh hier in der Sendung mal ausführlich dargestellt. Ich habe da auch ein.
Blogpost zugeschrieben, den ich nochmal verlinke. Ähm.
Kurz gesagt ging es da einem Angreifer darum ein Bottnitz äh aus äh Routern eines ganz anderen Herstellers.
Zusammenzuschalten und da das hat er versucht über eine Schwachstelle
In der Fernwartung Schnittstelle, ja, TR null sechs vier beziehungsweise TR null sechs neun. Hatten die Telekom Router und wenn man sich dort bei den Telekom-Routern hin verbunden hat, dann ging das
schon mal falsch ist, denn von außen aus dem freien Netz sollte eigentlich dieser Port an den Routern nicht erreichbar sein.
Ja, also die Telekom sollte nicht.
Die Fernwartungsschnittstelle, die ja nur für ihre eigenen Einstellungen ähm genutzt werden soll, dem gesamten Internet freigeben, sowas macht man eher in einem kleinen.
Management Faulan oder so, dass man den, dass man die Dinger nochmal in der internes VPN oder so holt, aber diese Schnittstelle dem freien Netz freizugeben.
Ist äh das Battle nach Problemen und das hat hier eben auch sehr.
Das hat hier eben auch stattgefunden, das hätte also diese Schnittstelle hätte nicht zugreifbar sein sollen, denn was passierte? Ähm,
diese Telekom-Route hatten das Problem, dass wenn mehrere Verbindungen dort innerhalb ähm sage ich mal von Minuten eingingen, sie irgendwann nicht mehr reagierten
Und zwar weil diese Geräte einen Fehler hatten, der bei
invaliden Paketen an, diese TR null sechs neun Schnittstelle und dieses was dorthin gesendet wurde, war ja eines ähm
jeweils eine äh Fehlverbindung stattgefunden hat und damit ein äh Teil CPU Last in einem Loop äh gefangen wurde. Das heißt, wenn du das jetzt akkumuliert hast, dann führte das dazu, dass die.
Nach einigen, nach mehreren solcher Zugriffen irgendwann gar nicht mehr funktionierten diese Geräte.
Und das führte zu dem Ausfall. Der Angreifer wiederum hatte äh sein Bot Netz so präpariert, dass jedes infizierte Gerät anfängt, dass ähm das gesamte V4 Internet,
wieder anzugreifen und äh zu versuchen zu infizieren. Und das bedeutet.
Du hast dann, wenn du erstmal eine eine nennenswerte Anzahlgeräte hast, natürlich diesen exponentiellen Effekt.
Und äh ich hatte glaube ich auch in der Sendung erzählt, dass ich da eben dann diese Angriffsversuche aus
Iran dem Vereinigten Königsreih, Königreich, Brasilien und noch einiger, ich glaube die Türkei war auch noch dabei, einige anderer Länder.
Registriert hatte und in diesen Ländern hat er also tatsächlich Geräte gehackt und dieser Telekom-Routerausfall,
war überhaupt nicht seine Absicht und sicherlich auch das, was ihm am Ende große Probleme bereitet hat, weil damit natürlich sehr viel mehr Leute auf ihn aufmerksam wurden, äh sehr viel mehr.
Ähm sage ich mal straf äh,
Strafverfolgungskompetenz auf diesen Fall geworfen wurde und das hat eben auch dazu geführt, dass er relativ flott äh gefangen wurde. Ich lese jetzt nicht
irgendwo bisher, wie sie's genau geschafft haben, würde aber davon ausgehen, dass sie entweder die initiale Infektion äh sehr gut forensisch untersucht haben und der da irgendwo Spuren hinterlassen hat. Ansonsten hat er glaube ich seine
seine Playlote nachgeladen über eine Domain, TH null sechs neun Punkt TW hieß die glaube ich.
Wenn ich das Recht entsinne, müsste ich nochmal nachschauen und ähm es kann natürlich gut sein, dass er bei der Registrierung dieser Domain irgendwie einen Fehler gemacht hat, ja? Also, dass er da irgendwo eine E-Mail-Adresse
angegeben hat, die zu ihm zurückverfolgt werden konnte oder bei der Registrierung der Domain.
Nicht ausreichend anonym vorgegangen ist. Sie werden sie irgendwann äh gekriegt haben, aber spannender Punkt, was kriegst du in Deutschland für äh knappe Millionen Telekom-Kunden vom Netz nehmen.
Ähm.
Unter dem mildernden Umstand, dass das nicht deine Absicht war und der konnte im Zweifelsfall auch äh glaubhaft erklären, dass das.
Dass er das nicht wissen konnte, dass äh die Telekom Router in diesem Zustand waren, dass sie eben eine andere Schwäche haben würden, die äh zu einem Ausfall führen würde.
Ähm ein Jahr und acht Monate bei entsprechender.
Reue, ja? Äh war der größte Fehler meines Lebens, weigert sich allerdings äh den Ermittlern das Passwort zu dem Laptop zu nennen, das bei seiner Verhaftung beschlagnahmt wurde, wird dem hier zu Last gelegt. Na ja, das würde ich auch nicht machen. Ähm.
Aber okay, der hat jetzt hier in Deutschland ein Jahr und acht Monate auf Bewährung bekommen, das heißt der äh.
Wird in Deutschland gar nichts Großartiges kriegen? Ähm.
Aber er landet in Auslieferungshaft denn äh der wird äh direkt wieder zurück.
Äh nach Großbritannien äh geführt, wo man eben äh mehrere andere ähm.
Äh Computer vergehen noch zu Lastlicht und,
hier ist auch einer der Gründe, warum man hier in Deutschland gesagt hat, na ja okay, komm zack, das wird jetzt einmal schnell abgeurteilt.
Und dann äh schicken wir dich weiter, der kann jetzt noch eine Tournee.
Machen äh an Ländern, wo er äh Gesetze mit den Gesetzen in Konflikt gekommen ist.
Ein äh anderer äh eine andere Kurzmeldung. Wir sehen immer, wenn ich Kurzmeldungen sage, wird's ein bisschen länger. Ähm ein anderer Fall für Kurzmeldungen ist der
BTC minus Efeil, der mich äh besonders ärgert und der große Ironie hat. Also BTC minus E ist ein Bitcoin Exchange.
War ein Bitcoin Exchange der inzwischen nicht mehr erreichbar ist, weil sein Betreiber verhaftet wurde. Und den wir zur Last gelegt
unter anderem bei BTC minus E primär äh quasi Geldfische ermöglicht, äh ermutigt und erleichtert zu haben. Also
ne? Das was eben immer noch eine der äh ja bestmöglichen oder eine der häufigen.
Sagen wir mal, eine der Anwendung von Bitcoin zu sein, äh die sehr auf der Hand liegen.
Ähm ist also Geldwäsche, ne? Also Bitcoin als Transaktionswährung. Man weiß nicht, wem die Wallets gehören mit anderen Worten. Wenn ich
die Beträge ein bisschen hin und her schiebe und an unterschiedlichen Stellen tausche,
in verschiedene Bitcoins oder Währungen kann ich das natürlich ganz gut zur Wäsche von Geld.
Nutzen.
Ich tatsächlich habe selber BTCE genutzt zur Spekulation, also zum Kaufen von billigen Bitcoins und Verkaufen von teuren Bitcoins und kann mich also kann also jetzt darüber klagen.
Dass diese wahrscheinlich auf immer verloren sind. Interessanterweise wurde dem aber noch ein zweites ein zweites Delikt zur Last gelegt
oder eine zweite Deliktklasse, nämlich dass er daran beteiligt gewesen sein soll,
Mount Gox betrogen zu haben, diesen anderen Bitcoin Exchange, der ja sehr groß war, ein, also der größte, glaube ich, insgesamt die äh eine Schwachstelle hatten, die es ermöglicht hatte.
Ähm quasi deren äh Clearing
so aus der Kraft zu setzen, dass sie nicht merken, dass sie sich selber um Geld betrügen, ja? Und so hat er die ja um große Summen Bitcoins
äh oder so konnten die um große Summen Bitcoins betrogen werden, sodass die irgendwann gemerkt haben, dass sie quasi Handel betrieben haben mit
Geld, von dem sie ausgegangen sind, dass es ihnen noch gehört, dass sie's aber gar nicht mehr haben und damit eben äh quasi als Handelsstelle insolvent waren. Äh auch sehr schön, also Mount Gogs ist da äh damals dann eben.
Äh ja, hat auch zugemacht und wurde dem Insolvenzverwalter übergeben, hatte eben äh viele hundert Bitcoin ähm.
Defizit in ihrer, in ihrer Handelsbilanz und war damit als Exchange platt. Und,
dieser Typ von BTCE wird jetzt beschuldigt, das getan zu haben. Was ihnen in meinen Augen zu einem Doppelarschloch macht, weil ich habe bei Mount Cox Geld verloren und bei BTCE und ähm bin jetzt also
mit diesem Bitcoin in in fremden Handelsplätzen ist also tatsächlich keine besonders gute Idee
Und das Spannende war, dass ich das tatsächlich ähm ich meine, es sind jeweils immer nur so irgendwie hundert Euro Beträge, die ich da verloren habe, insofern mein wirtschaftlicher Schaden hält sich in Grenzen.
Ähm aber wer mir helfen möchte, wieder äh ein Bitcoin Bitcoin Reichtum äh aufzubauen, der überweise dann in mein Wallet, wenn die Bitcoins niedrig sind. Im Moment stehen die ja gerade bei dreitausend oder so und ähm na ja.
Zweitausendsiebenhundert. Ich habe gerade nachgeschaut. Es ist.
Tausendsiebenhundert.
Nein, nein, zweitausendsiebenhundert.
Ah okay.
Na ja, also ja gut, ich habe eh gerade äh nur geringe Bitcoin Mengen zu verkaufen und wüsste auch nicht wo und wenn, dann würde ich's euch hier an dieser Stelle nicht empfehlen. Ähm ich, also das mit diesem Bitcoin da bin ich einfach nicht derjenige mit dem mit dem richtigen Händchen. Ich glaube, das Beste habe ich gemacht
bei den es im Miningpool, aber das ist auch schon äh wieder einige Zeit her und das ist glaube ich dann auch bei.
Bei Mont Gogs drauf gegangen. Also alles nicht so gut.
Ähm mit diesem mit diesem Bitcoin und äh wir haben noch ein anderes Bitcoin-Thema und ich werde mal schauen, ob wir es, ob es mir nicht leicht gelingt, da mit einem Experten mal eine Sondersendung zu machen, indem wir diese Themen nochmal ein bisschen
besser behandeln als ich das an dieser Stelle kann.
In der Firma. Ich habe letztens wieder mit einem Freund gesprochen, der seit Anfang an bei Bitcoin dabei ist und der hat schon irgendwie äh mit so drei D Welten,
Unmengen an linden Dollar verdient und die dann halt in Bitcoin umgewechselt, als die noch fast nichts wert waren und äh der hat sehr viel Geld gemacht. Also da.
Äh so äh Early Adapter kriegt ganz neue Konditationen äh und äh da mal eine Folge dazu zu machen. Ich glaube, es gibt noch sehr viele netzpolitische Implikationen.
Vor allem vielleicht auch so wirtschaftliche Implikationen, ähm die da noch auf uns zukommen.
Und da hat sich ja auch in den äh letzten Updates ähm Bitcoin-Netzwerk einiges getan.
Genau das Thema wollten wir auch noch behandeln. Sollen wir behandeln äh auf ausdrücklichen Hörerwunsch, wir werden schauen, ob wir da einen Experten für finden oder ob ich das machen muss.
Damit wären wir bei den Terminen.
Am zehnten November findet in Lübeck die Meta Look zweitausendsiebzehn statt. Unter dem Banner der Nights.
Open Knollege wird dort geladen äh zu einer lockeren, abendfüllenden Konferenz im Audimax der Universität zu Lübeck mit Vorträgen zu Technik, Wissenschaft und Gesellschaft. Es gibt eine hohe,
Breite an Themen äh der CFP ist eröffnet. Ihr könnt einreichen, Vorträge oder Workshops, Lightning Talks oder auch Stände
im Foyer unter Metanug DE Slash Sub mit.
Am einundzwanzigsten September findet der achtzehnte netzpolitische Abend statt. Äh eigentlich ist das der netpolitische Abend in Wien, aber dieses Mal gibt's eine Exkursion nach Sankt
Böthen in das Herz von Niederösterreich und dort gibt's mit einer Kooperation der glaube ich lokalen FH,
Einen jetzt politischen Abend mit besonders hochkarätigem äh Gästen. Wir verlinken auf die Details.
Und vom sechsten bis achten Oktober findet in Hannover wieder der Hackover statt. Äh
die Hackover Global Conference war es äh beim vorletzten Mal, wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Ich muss jetzt mal ganz kurz schauen
äh ah jetzt stürzt hier alles ab, meine Güte, ich wusste äh ohne den Tipp Tim, wir vermissen dich, okay, kannste wiederkommen, bitte. Ähm also der Hackover ist, glaube ich, hier regelmäßig angekündigt worden. Han ist die Hannoveraner
Konferenz des Chaos-Computerclubs dort und der CFP ist eröffnet, der Presell ist eröffnet und einmal bitte.
Klicken.
Am zehnten September in Linz gibt es den Grundrechtstag der österreichischen Richtervereinigung, eine sehr spannenden Organisation und äh
Der schöne Titel ist Luxusmenschenrechte, Fragezeichen. Ähm da muss man sich anmelden und äh das auch nur, wenn mit einem wirklich das Programm gefällt, aber meistens sehr spannende Diskussionen
Und adeas letzte Event ist äh sind ganz viele Vernetzungstreffen äh zum Überwachungspaket in Linz, Graz.
Krems und Fillach über den August verteilt und äh Details dazu findet man auf Epicenter dot works Slash Kalender.
Ihr habt es vielleicht gemerkt, dass die Termine nicht chronologisch waren, insofern äh genau darauf achten, welche Daten wir jetzt angegeben haben. Ich glaube, der nächste Termin war der, den wir als letztes angesagt haben.
Ja, weil ich fast konologisch aber umgekehrt. Du hast die Sortierung nicht genannt.
Wunderbar, äh also äh Sort Minus, was weiß ich, was ist Reverse bedeutet. Damit sind wir am Ende.
In dieser Sendung zumindest. Es sei denn, dir fällt noch was ein Thomas.
Nee, ich glaube, wir haben's einigermaßen ähm.
Abgefrühstückt und ich hoffe es war eine gute Sendung. Ich habe äh Tim nicht ersetzen können, aber vielleicht ein ein äh ja guter Exkurs äh für die deutschsprachigen Österreicher.
Ja, aber äh ich vermute das ja auch bei den anderen Podcasts, gerade Sommerpause ist äh nicht nur in der Meta-Ebene. Insofern äh.
Ja wahrscheinlich sind die Termine eh unnötig, weil äh Podcasts, die im Sommer erscheinen, die hört man doch dann erst im September irgendwie, oder?
Ist das so.
Ich weiß nicht im Urlaub mache ich auch immer Podcast Pause, News Pause, Podcast Pause, E-Mail-Pause, ein paar Medien muss man auch mal zur Seite legen, damit man runterkommt.
Das äh das würde mich mal interessieren, das kann man ja mal äh im, also ich nicht, ich äh kann ich bin ja ich suchte Podcasts ja hart und äh ich kann da nicht einfach äh von lassen.
Und äh brauche dann auch im Urlaub Versorgung.
Ähm bin mal gespannt, wie ihr das so haltet und vor allem würde mich tatsächlich mal so ein bisschen interessieren, wenn man das mal in den Kommentaren schreiben könnte. Wir sagen ja jetzt seit einiger Zeit auch die.
Das Datum an, vielleicht fällt euch bei der Gelegenheit auf wie tagesaktuell ihr dann auch Logbuch Netzpolitik hört.
Also viele schreiben ja, ich höre immer jede Folge sofort, wenn sie rauskommt am gleichen Tag. Ähm von einigen weiß ich aber auch, dass sie äh so ein bisschen mit.
Mit Verzögerung hören oder dann höre ich mal im Gespräch, dass sie sagen, ach ja, nee, die die letzte habe ich noch nicht gehört, äh obwohl die eine Woche alt ist, weil äh keine Ahnung äh auch andere Podcasts im Feed sind oder so. Äh das würde es mir teilweise
so ein bisschen helfen, da mal eine grobe Einschätzung zu bekommen.
Wobei es kommentieren ja ohnehin sehr viel weniger als die Sendung hören. Äh insofern weiß ich nicht, ob das repräsentativ ist. Vielleicht muss ich da irgendwann mal eine Umfrage machen oder sowas.
Würde mich auf jeden Fall mal interessieren und ähm damit sind wir dann glaube ich.
Äh Ende der Sendung angelangt. Ich danke dir Thomas.
Und ich danke außerdem Enrico, Thomas Niklas.
Und Ronny und einer unbekannten Person und wie immer, wenn ich einer unbekannten Person.
Danke freue ich mich, wenn du dich bei mir meldest, ein Kontaktformular findest du bei mir unter Linus Minus Neumann Punkt DE Slash Kontakt.
Das war's. Ciao ciao.